yeah this is right after it was official
this is so crazy that I'm just talking
about this and then this I believe is
the final photo the one I took of Jenna
when we got home
Ronnie laid right down on her dress the
moment we got home yep Jenna Marbles is
a married woman the most incredible
thing on Thursday gamer Julian solomita
announced the exciting news that he and
the former YouTuber tied the knot after
nine years together married the girl in
my dreams I'm a married man can't
believe it Julian shared a few photos
from their wedding on Instagram with the
caption married otters the post quickly
received love in the comments from
friends and fans including PewDiePie
iJustine Alessia Cara and Brittany
Broski yeah what the hell in a YouTube
Vlog Julian shared more details about
those sweet picks taken on their big day
this is us getting ready the morning
before we left so yes her dress is
absolutely amazing
um we thrifted both of our outfits
her dress was thrifted and my whole suit
was thrifted kind of a Vibe and um yeah
Bob was there yeah this is right after
it was official
this is so crazy that I'm just talking
about this I drove around town
with this on the back of my car for far
too long like I pushed two weeks before
I washed it off because I just didn't
want it to go Jenna's been out of the
spot like the past couple years
following her YouTube Fame if you have
something floating in your drink then
you know you're ready seriously what's
in my drink aliens still gonna drink it
just be like you know what I know where
my eyebrows are close your eyes Okay the
online personality left social media
YouTube included in 2020 after receiving
backlash over past controversial videos
which she has since apologized for I
want to hold myself accountable
um
and it's painful to do it and it's not
fun and it hurts and I'm ashamed of
things I've done inside in my past but
um it's important now fast forward to
April 2021 and Julian casually dropped
the news about their engagement during a
twitch stream a little while ago I asked
Jenna to marry me and she said yes so we
are engaged she is still offline as you
know but
still very much part of my life and
since the two got hitched Julian
couldn't hold back the exciting news any
longer it feels good to let you all know
because I know you know
Jenna's life and my life and our
relationship has been
shared with y'all for a long time even
though not so much recently but
we wanted you guys to know
[Music]